très chère reine tu es folle de
me donner un palais c'est une
extravagance monstrueuse c'est Molly nous sommes en guerre
nous avons gagné ce qui n'est pas fini nous devons
continuer oh non je ne savais pas que la
reine est une personne extraordinaire je peux
dire même si je peux  je ne vois pas et j'ai entendu le
mot gros et laid personne d'autre que moi
n'oserait et je ne l'ai pas fait
elle a été traquée par la tragédie tout le monde
me laisse meurt je m'excuse pour mon
apparence j'espérais que je pourrais être employé
ici par vous comme quelque chose un monstre pour
le  des enfants avec qui jouer c'est peut-être
important de se faire de nouveaux amis au tribunal
n'est-ce pas oui monsieur beau
arrêtez vous vous moquez de moi si j'étais un homme
j'aurais ravi ici vous avez un
rapprochement Abigail c'est une vipère vous êtes
jaloux  vous renvoyez loin je ne
veux pas parier tirer quelque chose parfois il
est difficile de se rappeler si vous avez
chargé le plomb ou non nous devons prendre le
contrôle de ma situation je suis
toujours de mon côté la faveur est une brise qui
change de direction tout le temps  temps
puis en un instant tu es b  ack dormir
avec un groupe de [ __ ] scabreuses
car il s'avère que je suis capable de beaucoup de
désagréments Goodyear me regarde
[Musique]
Je ne pouvais pas rester là et te laisser
me détruire joie
c'est amusant d'être reine d'une manière ou d'une autre
va arrêter de te donner des coups de pied ne t'arrêtera pas
mon cher ami comme c'est bon de voir que
tu es revenu de l'enfer
je suis sûr que tu y passeras un
jour
[Musique]
toi